hi i'm riya i'm a tasty producer in l.a
today i'm going to be showing you how to
make most mesmerizing japanese dessert
japanese people including me are
obsessed with seasons cherry blossom
season it's such a short amount of time
so from the end of march to beginning of
april a lot of people go for picnics
hiking and have a party under the cherry
blossoms it's my favorite season and i
miss japan so much especially around
this time of the year because l.a has no
seasons
i think our ancestors started to
preserve these beautiful flowers so they
could enjoy it longer
traditionally raindrop cake in japanese
we call mizushimochi
it's made with agar agar agar agar is a
jelly like substance made from algae so
unlike gelatin it's vegetarian agar
itself has no flavor so raindrop cake
tastes like sugar water jello so pour
your favorite syrup on top japanese
people also value beautiful looking
desserts and food no offense to your
brownies or chocolate chip cookies those
are delicious but maybe not quite as
visually pleasing you are also eating
with your eyes and this raindrop cake is
a perfect example the cherry blossoms
are encased in a drop of water it
reminds me of cherry blossom on a rainy
day
[Music]
i think mochi is getting popular all
over the world the powder i used for
this video called shira tamako is made
with rice flour i used matcha for the
ice cream flavor matcha is powdered
green tea packed with antioxidants and
boosts your metabolism so you can eat
much ice cream without feeling guilty
mochi is super easy to make and easy to
work with but it is very sticky so make
sure you use a lot of starch on the
surface typically mochi is made with
steamed mochi rice and eaten mainly
around new year's however the mochi we
used for mochi ice cream we call gyuhi
used all year round i like matcha flavor
because it's a little bitter so it's a
good balance to the ice cream i made
this video for tasty japan i wanted to
make a much ice cream video but much ice
cream it's cheap so i was wondering how
i could convince our audience to make
much ice cream and i was like okay let's
make it giant because i've never seen
giant mochi ice cream before if you
don't have matcha you can use cocoa
powder or strawberry jam after we
published the video i saw that some of
our audience actually made it and tagged
us on instagram account it made me very
happy it's one of the best feeling i get
from being a tasty video producer as i
mentioned earlier japanese people are
obsessed with seasonal ingredients
pumpkin and chestnut flavors are very
popular during the fall season we used
kabucha pumpkins for our video cabocho
is the most popular pumpkin in japan
they are sweet and drier texture than
butternut squash perfect for baking and
cooking and i love using them kabocha is
getting popular in america i can find
them in grocery stores easily japanese
people have started celebrating
halloween but halloween in japan is more
popular among adults dressing up in
costumes not for trick-or-treating some
of the western traditional holidays are
misinterpreted in japan we celebrate
christmas but it is more like a romantic
holiday for couples so this kabocha
pumpkin pudding was made by tasty japan
producer saki but she was struggling
with unmolding the pudding so i learned
this cool trick on the internet
this is how to a mold pudding in a bun
pan so hold tight your bum pan and plate
and you just spin
okay made me a little bit dizzy but
pudding is a molded
so this pumpkin pudding it's not your
typical halloween treats but i think
it's really pretty because of the color
contrast yellow and shiny brown and also
when you pour the chocolate i feel like
it looked like a spiderweb so i think
it's a perfect halloween dessert
some of you watching this video might
have seen this recipe already but stay
with me it's one of the most viewed and
shared tasty japan video
i didn't know how deeply orange the yolk
of the egg until i moved from japan to
the states as you can see tasty producer
albin made the video in japan so the egg
yolk is very orange alvin and i went to
japan together a year ago for research
purposes albe was obsessed with this
jiggly cheesecake that he saw on the
internet
we went to the store and watched how
they make them so this cheesecake you
can eat year around but i chose it for
winter dessert because you want to enjoy
while it's hot you want to eat it right
after it came out from the oven so i
think this is the perfect dessert for
winter
i've started cooking more and more since
i moved to the united states mainly as a
homesickness cure
even though i'm not physically home it
feels like home wherever i am when i
cook and eat japanese food i didn't have
a lot of friends when i moved to the
states but whenever you meet new people
i've found talking about food it's a
great icebreaker regardless of their age
gender or race everyone has their own
personal stories about food i love
everything about japanese dessert and
culture i'd love to hear your stories
oh yes
[Music]
you